the scene that happens after your talk
in the garage in season 2 is one of the
most powerful in my opinion at least for
Judy because she's basically spent the
large majority of the series directing
all of her anger inwards towards herself
and she's finally kind of letting it
come out and directing it directing it
at someone else so just for you did that
moment kind of feel like I don't know
like a weight has lifted or a big
release because the character was going
through that kind of experience yeah
it's actually really challenging is one
of the biggest challenges of the part
although I have to say this a lot of
challenges with that part luckily so I'm
so lucky but one of them is it's so much
easier to play anger than it is to
deflect all of the things that judy has
it's much easier to let things escalate
in a scene and let it feel good and get
it out you know yeah we a moat but
there's this thing about anger that
would you lock in especially if you lock
in an argument it's it was it took
retraining myself not to be angry so
some of that is evident and how locked
up it is in even in my body so the you
know that is a huge release and it's
something that I was waiting to do just
personally as and as an actor because
I'm hanging on to so much in my body
that just to being able to do that felt
good and you want the audience to feel
like it's earned at some point too but
then she turns right back around and
takes it out herself
so yeah and I I think that that's a
fascinating piece of the character and
it's something that we sort of stumbled
upon in the first season that wasn't
exactly written and and just came from
me sort of researching people who are
who can't quite get angry and how it
turns into this self-loathing and I
don't know it can turn into to other
things that way wait I okay to follow up
on that first have you guys ever talked
about maybe exploring like
it's kind of like the toxicity of
friendships a little because now I'm
thinking that in all in all of season
one judy is constantly saying sorry to
Steve and then she's kind of adjust and
does that with Jen too so are there any
lingering effects that we might see
continue on from there back and forth in
that respect possibly I mean here's the
thing Liz will tell me as much as she
knows when I ask but and whatever it is
that she comes up with her and the
writer is there they're so phenomenal it
is something that I would have never
thought of so but there's most things
are there for a reason I think with
Jamie because there are so many turns
and twists and and that there are seeds
planted for reasons and I think they
come back and they come back around and
I it's always a great joy to me when I
when I realize what I'm reading it oh
that's something that we laid out in you
know in Episode one that now we're
seeing it sort of crop up in Episode
seven that I love that I couldn't agree
more I think that's part of the reason
why it can be an absolute hilarious
blast but also have real meaning not
just to the characters but just lessons
about forgiveness that you could take
with you and growth and self-worth so I
love that one more spoiler question
before I leave this territory here so in
season 2 Jen connected and won but the
thing is the gray area in this one is a
lot different because Jen actually
killed someone she murdered someone so
what were kind of the I guess the
conversations you guys had behind the
scenes in order to make sure that even
though she did do that to Steve the
audience is still rooting for her to get
away with it yeah well that's the trick
of the show I mean that's me is the most
incredible thing that lives manages to
do but the show is you would never in a
million years
want Jen and Duty to be friends if you
read on paper what in the first season
necessarily what had happened the I and
I always felt like if you can root for
them to be friends we have accomplished
the impossible because it's
counterintuitive in some ways yet when
Liz lays it out it seems so true somehow
and natural that you want that to happen
and I think that also is you know
between Christina and I on set - we have
just such a wonderful relationship and a
wonderful working relationship and and I
think that that that texture really
helps it feel beyond all of the
circumstances that are happening in the
plot season - you know I it's
interesting because judy forgives fast
in some ways and for me it was a
wonderful challenge to be able to make
that forgiveness seem really earnest and
and true and it is she doesn't want it
in and I think that I think how I wrote
it was so was so beautiful I was just as
you know she's tired of feeling sad and
angry and to be to be doing that just to
to sort of not forgive her would be
punishment for herself and I think that
is very true for Judy but would not be
true for other people it plays oh well
like I find it so interesting when I
have a feeling that I can't assess in a
you know in a written review kind of way
exactly why I'm like okay I'm glad this
happens with this oh she did what she
did it's a very difficult thing to
process but you guys pull it off so well
and kind of did exactly what you just
described thank you well that's life
right you don't necessarily love all the
people you should yeah you you know what
I mean you don't know you don't make the
right decisions when you know you could
have and and so I think that's the
complexity of the relationships and for
me too and Judy more and Steve the way
that she does that is as complex and for
that reason makes it real